in their previous episode yeah I'm
taking my OB how's it going best
my name is welcomed by Olli shed there's
a dog damn holy sharper look at that I'm
graphics look at this look look why
don't you lucky I can say that you're
not luck anyway we're gonna go oh [ __ ]
the dog is prey oh oh go go go
oh no no this is the Johnson that's
expect ok go conquer go look at
well talk about a faceplant there's
money over there this [ __ ] chick is
so awesome
ah man ah man I keep saying it but I
feel like this should be more okay so
now I can get the money is that oh yes I
was just thinking about you guy what is
he doing
[ __ ] the dead shark there we go of
course that's what I why that's what I
like what some great stuff I don't want
I will [ __ ] grab all of you alright
how much are cool
I'll bail get within my mortgage and buy
my car my car hurry call why are we
gonna get a gat for card for you 700
only that means we need 300 more what
the [ __ ] oh well I don't know if you
guys remember when we need a thousand
and a thousand dollars to get past where
we are um yeah I guess we're gonna head
back then I think I came this way
honestly not sure for catch fishes you
didn't eat all of them don't cry I know
I saw that you were a little sad when he
ate them but that's okay what's the kind
of a sad
gay just kidding I shed this tornado
thingy that wallop em all right
I was thinking next we should help that
[ __ ] girl that's a flower I are all
right all right Brett Connor is playing
with a yo-yo I don't really know where
to go the music combined with these
[ __ ] camera angles this I don't know
it's kind of pissing me off but I found
this place and I found a ladder here and
then let's go up our adventure Ching the
adventure song you don't know the
adventure song hahaha
sometimes you bros don't even what is
this a jacuzzi
what's going on wha [ __ ] I fell down the
Yangtze oh I can swim down here
what the [ __ ] is he doing what are you
doing conkers I guess I gotta empty the
[ __ ] water or some [ __ ] like that I
guess I should have realized that no no
no no I spat that bought a five on that
there we go Pat its that's Spanish and
Italian combined [ __ ] itchy face no
you little deck sucker
ah we're fine more fine piss pills is
not pissed anymore because you got a
drink piss to be pissed all right can I
make it over there do you both think I
can do it you don't well I need some
[ __ ] encouragement right now so maybe
you can just kidding
you look beautiful today I tell you that
I own that it's Valentine's Day when I'm
recording this so yeah how you doing you
want to be my Valentine girl just
kidding hahaha sorry it's not about that
oh I nail it you can be my Valentine all
right here we go why the hell am I going
I know nobody's no one just let's just
get up here browse I love [ __ ] love
how he climbs like that
go on whoa somebody heart
my heart will go on every night in my
dreams I see you I fear you
there is someone out there father all
singing it's only because it's
Valentine's Day I actually sang multiple
times without being yeah my Charlotte
whoa whoa whoa bro ChaCha's are we doin
what I think we're doing because I don't
want to be doing what I think I'm in be
doing I don't know are you scared of
heights I don't really like [ __ ] we're
[ __ ] Bros okay it's okay to be fine
that's a canopy [ __ ] read a book this is
not the time for beaver porn Jade says
[ __ ] Justin Bieber man you [ __ ] it
hmm maybe we can get the money all right
clap clap Rose do it don't think you're
too cool a clap [ __ ] crap all right
here we go
yeah write it off what the hell you do
it what Allah what the hell is that good
for why the hell we did it let's do that
again for my bro ChaCha's did I miss
that [ __ ]
hahaha yeah you know what I know
something you don't know you want to
know it right I'm not gonna tell it I
don't know I felt like being mysterious
today how about that how about that
don't you [ __ ] squish me there we go
I think I know where the entrance is
that's what I know do you know why this
maybe you do know what at it
[ __ ] this is really awkward that right
edge why did you tell me like half an
hour ago would it save me a lot of time
you know what what side I can't whoa
what is this
looks like wow this is creepy
what the [ __ ] yeah um I'm gonna go I was
nice meeting you over there yeah yeah
you the small one apparently was
something we'll meet inside this bond
uh-huh I can't quite see it myself
uh-huh lesyk awesome guys jumping around
thinking a hospice real neat ha ha ha ha
crap it isn't miss a car [ __ ] [ __ ] ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha this is pretty neat
oh no it's not oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] : what
the hell did you do I didn't know the
new telekinesis really Frankie Oh
Frankie I think there's a little photo
over there just going into the door
uh-huh
I think it's your turn to kick is it
your turn baby you okay that daddy's
always match over to kick your asses
Frances Gerety disaster
tell me back exacting I mean me Anna
right yeah you don't kick anyway I'm a
baby okay can come a weird okay
Oh tom ah [ __ ] the cutscenes are like no
other [ __ ] JP then I'm like a
paintbrush doctor damn diddly-squat a
touch like me let a day of our well I
never to talking pitchbook knots around
here hurry boy no I'm from the 21st and
hahahaha the wick leg black in your type
therefore I concluded I was gonna kick
you butt all around this barn that was
no no no it's gonna stick my big bull
riding is wheel parents related like
before Luo man I'm gonna give you a
whoopin here we go
no no no what bang I shed it uses it ah
but he do it stop right you think you're
oh s at that but oh you like that don't
you [ __ ] is up with the music I just do
our stuff very much are they kill stuff
[ __ ] murders them all right well jib
muttering them days poor haze man on the
[ __ ] eyes turn on you
why am I supposed to kill these exactly
why a tiny one I guess this is one I
really needed um okay so we kill all the
Hey
am I supposed to do something I'm
kicking ass Mac Jack and that is the
crappers crappiest this kick ass that is
the best son desire hurry
kick ass kicking ass goes it was abysmal
and who is it
bastard stupid bastard hey it's me yep
yeah it sure is
Joe what are you gonna do now can you
recommend oh man we got a rope right
here and we got it over here we got a
roach come on we're gonna friend to you
oh the kid is gonna keep myself I'm not
done that's all there is to it you do it
[ __ ] I'm just kidding
dad's getting oh there's a money there I
can get that money that cash get money
oh he killed himself
you stupid bastard
it was got a net energy to be better
than a [ __ ] you ain't gonna Eddie I
already said that I don't appear to have
ain't I got a [ __ ] I haven't making it
it ain't gonna stop with this
oh dude be damned well it's gonna be me
for some time scare some pockets too bad
never Envy baby I always think like a
well it's been stupid for a while now I
guess it won't be forever what the plug
in that alley that gang hub from I don't
even [ __ ] I don't know anymore Prez
when he brought suggested Conker's Bad
Fur Day you know I heart is gonna be
offensive and weird I did not have this
in mind like what is this one I gotta
miss you guys you were awesome good
alright so we open up for the B [ __ ] or
whatever can I leave now
yes I can
uh-huh what the frak what the hell
so my nemesis day what why are they
looking at his ass yes it's me again oh
no it's the giant eight hey [ __ ] time to
wander around
Amos oh the pitchfork what this never
says now I get it
time to walk around aimlessly man my
[ __ ] [ __ ] in a duck stock hey what's
up
are you two in there are you right to
spur me to die sure man hey buddy don't
ignore Poli always ignore me
oh you want to die man for my old
culture I'm a king yeah really huh-huh
head is fine dumb [ __ ] threw me up
apparently the hive keeps getting stolen
right okay well I got it back for him
now sing anyway no [ __ ] you [ __ ] States
or oh no well yeah anyway please tell me
it's not interesting you like the rest
of them ah come on are you gonna tell
you about the big breasted babe men
hello
now they're big white egg what uh-huh
thought that buddy got their attention
she's lovely
that's why the wife kicked me out
what I wanna do is pollinator pollinate
and Scott's tumors like you wouldn't
believe
what do you mean I thought you said you
had thing yeah over there behind us
Oh shed what the [ __ ]
no second where she's a sunflower
yeah what the [ __ ] you expected to me
some flour wheat bread imma be stupid
bastard okay I'd like to get offended
now sorry you gotta help me out buddy I
don't know what I'm gonna do
Wow hmm I thin it for me suss me ha
just ten all right let's give him some
[ __ ] cash I don't understand anything
I'm so [ __ ] of yours they should
really have big boobs or is it something
to do with the sunflower then what do
you want I really don't get it I get the
feeling we're gonna see something weird
right now
motorboat
what what
uh-huh
all right purchase it looks like I will
have to enter Saturday's
but I'm very happy I got sky color and a
duck